if you are investing your time on the
things that matter to you then you will
be happier you will be more satisfied
and it's not more as better it is just
being intentional and spending the time
in ways that matter to you
are basically a happiness
in particularly focusing on the role of
time for our happiness
why are those two things intrinsically
linked
well because the way we spend the hours
of our day sum up to our the years of
our life and so
the time that we spend is the fabric of
our life and from that we are either
more or less happy and when I say happy
what I mean is the joy that we
experience in our days as well as the
satisfaction we feel about our lives so
there's both that emotional feeling
within as well as evaluative and
cognitive feeling about
um that both of those are linked to and
when I say the word happy and feeling
happier which is really the goal and you
know part of the title of my book
um that's what I'm talking about
interesting I remember reading a summary
of Don Gilbert and Daniel kahneman's two
approaches of what they thought about
happiness the lying in the pool with a
cocktail on the LIE low for the rest of
your life yes it's not meaningful but
you enjoyed every second individually
and then the other version that was like
a meaningful one and it seems like
you're or definition of Happiness here
kind of combines the two it's the state
enjoyment in the moment and it's the
retrospective feeling of being satisfied
about how your life has gone and about
each moment as it was spent is that the
commonly held definition when we talk
about happiness in the literature in the
science at the moment is that what
people mean when they refer to happiness
um it is the sort of what the literature
refers to the term that they say is
subjective well-being and that is the
coupling of this emotional component so
feeling more positive than negative
emotion as well as satisfaction about
um and notably there are instances in
which they do sort of come apart but
as I'm not even just talking about the
literature but really about the
implications for us as individuals and
how we should be spending our time what
I am going for is that coupling like we
both want to feel happy and satisfied
while is happening but also have it have
an impact on our evaluation of how good
life is and how meaningful and
meaningful is actually our meaning is is
a little bit of a separate construct
um but in our research we've actually
looked at what's the correlation between
how happy people are feeling and how
meaningful they feel like their life is
and they're so highly correlated and
yeah there are instances where again you
can pull them apart but as I'm striving
to feel sort of good in and about my
life and I think that that's what a lot
of individuals are striving for that's
the operationalization and of this idea
this construct using scientific jargon
but basically that's our goal to feel
happy within and happy about and really
it's about feeling joy and fulfillment
so that's the goal what are the biggest
predictors of happiness and life
satisfaction
well if you look at the all the studies
that have happiness as a dependent
variable as the outcome you see that a
big
thing that has an effect is our natural
disposition so our personality
um and
so like are you a naturally half
glassful type person
um or are you a natural Grump
um now that has a big effect
um and it is important to recognize but
I don't Focus as much on that because we
don't have control over that
um another thing that does have an
impact on our happiness is our
circumstances and our life circumstances
so these are things like income level
attractiveness marital status and
interestingly these things are the ones
that a lot of people are like if only I
have that then I'll be happy and that's
what they're sort of striving for
if only I had a lot of money then I
would be happy if only I met the love of
my life and got married then I'd be
happy if only I was super gorgeous and I
would be happy and the research shows
looking at the correlation the
relationship between those circumstances
and happiness that there is a
relationship but it's significantly
smaller than we think and the answer is
no if only you had a lot of money would
you be happy and happy forever the
answer is no for that if only you were
super gorgeous would you be happy and
happy forever the answer is no for that
if you found the love of your life and
got married
would you be happy forever the answer is
no for that and so also our life
circumstances are largely out of our
day-to-day control so again that's not
something I focus on what I focus on is
this final chunk this input into
happiness that does and science show has
a significant effect and actually a
significantly larger effect than we
think and that is what we do and our
mindset in the day-to-day and I
particularly am focused through this
lens of Time how we spend our time and
how we think about our time has a
significant influence on our happiness
and this is where we have choice and
this is why I'm interested in it because
if we understand the science and know
our informed okay what has been
validated as having a significant effect
on how we feel in our days and how
satisfied we feel about our lives well
great then we can make the choice the
day-to-day choices to implement those
insights and then feel happier in our
days and more satisfied about our lives
what are the ways in which the happiest
people spend their time then
well the research points to some
averages so it looking at time tracking
research what those folks the
researchers do is look over the course
of people's days what are what
activities are they doing as well as how
they're feeling over the course of the
day so that you can identify okay what
are those activities that on average are
associated with the most positive
emotion what are those activities on
average are associated with the most
negative emotion
that research points to the happiest
activities are those that involve social
connection so whether through intimacy
or spending time with family and friends
the activities that are associated with
the least amount of Happiness on average
tend to be commuting
work and housework so that's a bummer
and we can talk about how to address
that but I think what's even more
helpful for folks and listeners is not
thinking about averages but actually
when and which I describe this process
and this exercise that is so helpful
in happier hour is basically tracking
your own time so over the course of a
week writing down what are you doing
what activities are you doing or what
activity are you doing and every half
hour and there's a worksheet on my
website in case helpful but really is
writing down what you're doing and being
more specific not just work or
socializing but what work activity are
you doing and if you're socializing who
who are you with and what are you doing
and as importantly is as you're coming
out of that activity how did that
activity make you feel not the sort of
global is like I like to do this and I
don't like to do this but having spent
your time doing that how do you feel on
a 10-point scale and this is so helpful
because at the end of the week you have
this fantastic personalized data set so
you can look all right what are those
activities that got my highest ratings
what were those that really made me feel
happy and satisfied and joyful what are
those activities that are like not at
all happy you also can see just how much
time you're spending across your various
activities so you can sort of pick up on
like holy cow I spent a whole lot of
time on this activity that got like
fours in my ratings and it's not even
all that necessary so that's informative
in itself maybe reallocate that what I
would say is wasted time into time and
that is more joyful in which you now
know what types of activities those are
because you have the data right there in
front of you is there anything
interesting about happiness differences
between experienced and remembered
activities or events
there is
um and but again I'm going for the ones
that have the devil
will provide on both and what's nice
about the time tracking that you do for
yourself is that as you're coming out of
the experience it's capturing both
how you felt in it because it's really a
sort of close memory but also how you're
feeling about but yes research does pick
up on TV watching but interestingly so
like TV watching is shown to be quite
mediocre on
um sort of meaning but on the average
American the average viewing of TV
actually gets pretty high rating so
there you see a disconnect but what's
cool about the individual
um data that you collect and I teach a
course on this so applying the science
of Happiness to life design so over
years I've had my MBA students and
Executive MBA students do this and so I
see these patterns from their
observations
what's sort of interesting is TV
rarely shows up among people's happiest
activities in their the sort of broad 10
point uh rating but what's also
interesting you see and you can see like
actually that first hour of TV is sort
of fun right it's like after that long
day of work and you pour yourself a
glass of wine and you're settling into
that first episode it's totally
delightful but what happens often and
what we see in um you know our own time
tracking data is that when we say yes to
or do you want to view the next episode
and those evenings of binge watching by
hour two and three actually your
happiness ratings even your enjoyment
ratings have plummeted
um and so that also is really insightful
being like okay and I can explain the
psychology behind the fact that we get
used to things over time so hedonic
adaptation and is our psychological
propensity to get used to stuff after
doing the same thing over a continued
period of time doing the same thing
repeatedly over time spending time with
the same person over time we get used to
those so it has less of a emotional
impact than it did initially now it's
good that we adapt in the face of bad
stuff because it makes us resilient it's
less painful over time we become more
tolerant but the bummer is that we also
get used to good stuff
so I mean that explains why something
that is like quote unquote enjoyable
like watching TV initially yes it is
fine but over time it stops having as
strong of an impact and so that has some
implications for how we structure our
time in terms of you should actually
spread out the good activities so that
that sort of initial starting that
intensity
um uh has this as strong of an effect as
possible but it's not only over the
course of hours within the day it's also
really important to recognize this in
the Days of Our Lives because you know
we were talking about you know as sort
of
the activity of watching TV but think of
something way more profoundly
potentially joyful than that is like
spending time with the people you love
and you think about the very first time
that your partner said I love you right
the impact of that is like fireworks in
your like heart and mind like it's so
impactful
but then those words I love you over
years got shortened to love you and you
sort of say it as you're hanging up the
phone or walking out the door you don't
even hear the words like the meaning
behind those words and if something as
profound as like a declaration of Love
is something that we get used to such
that it stops having the same emotional
impact that is something to take into
account and to try to offset in the
happiness that we feel in our days right
again that's what we want is like to
feel Joy within our days and satisfied
about our lives and so some of the
exercises and advice that I give based
off of the studies is basically how do
we not only figure out what activities
to spend more time on and to maximize
our time on but also how do we engage in
those happiest activities
so that we actually experience the
happiness that is potentially there
within that time that we're already
spending and not miss out on it what are
some of the strategies there other than
uh I guess chunking stuff down into
smaller more frequent exposures so that
the hedonic slope doesn't drop off quite
so quickly what else can people do yeah
so breaking it up which is what you just
said so having breaks between
um The Happy activities infusing variety
is another so
um research shows for instance that
couples who engage in novel experiences
together
um report greater relationship
satisfaction and last longer in their
relationships and it's because those
novel experiences Infuse variety and so
by doing various like different things
together it keeps you engaged it keeps
you paying attention and you're sort of
dealing that with your partner
another is recognizing that even though
these things might seem every day
recognizing that they are not inevitably
going to continue happening every day
our time is finite and when you actually
recognize just how limited times left
are that absolutely draws our attention
and so one of the exercises which is
actually quite poignant is if you I you
know reflect back on your last couple
weeks and what was an activity that
really brought you Joy
oftentimes it's these very mundane
moments or like ordinary moments
um and count count how many times you
have left and actually the first step is
counting how many times have you done
this activity in your life so far
then count how many times do you have in
your life left to do this activity
accounting for the fact that factors in
your life are likely to change
accounting for the fact that if that
joyful activity involved another person
circumstances of their life and their
availability is going to likely change
and then recognizing or counting
calculating really the percentage of all
your times of doing that activity you
have left and so often we recognize that
holy cow
I have less than half and in some cases
it's like eight percent
um like one of the examples
um I had my students uh do this exercise
one of the students he calculated time
spent
um watching sports with his best friend
on the couch and he calculated so how
many times has he done that in his life
I mean it was a sort of funny exercise
and he was like embarrassed and proud to
you know including all those days after
school in Middle School in high school
but then they went off to college and
then it was like Christmas breaks for
two weeks on you know they would be on
the couch watching TV and sports
together but then they continued living
in different cities and had a girlfriend
and so then it was like visits included
partners and then the his best friend
had as a two-year-old so
even when they visit each other being
able to spend some hours on the couch
with just this buddy watching sports
like they are very limited and doing
that calculation he realized that in his
life he has only eight percent of times
on his couch watching whether it's his
couch or his friend Scouts basically
watching sports with his buddy
left and that is really impactful so
what does that make you do well it makes
you
prioritize that time so actually during
the break of that class he went in and
called his buddies like dude we need to
um play on a guy's weekend but also
during that time it makes you Savor and
soak up that time more
um and I share in the book my
calculation with my coffee dates with my
daughter
and this these coffee dates are so like
it actually was born out of a very
functional thing of me needing caffeine
and stopping at a coffee shop on my way
to drop her off and into my office and
she's tagging along as the little
preschooler but what we did and this is
another strategy to keep paying
attention is turning a routine into a
ritual
and so this ritual that my daughter and
my coffee date we gave it a name
Thursday morning coffee dates and now
even though we've shifted had to shift
it to Saturday mornings we still call it
our Thursday morning coffee date and we
like listen to the same songs we order
the same things and it is just this
special time 30 minutes each week for
the two of us to be together and I
calculated how many times have we had a
coffee date together in the past and
including during my maternity leave
where I would like sort of bundle her up
and take her to the coffee shop because
that was my like source of sanity and
then our weekly coffee dates I
calculated that we've had about 400
coffee dates together in our life so far
and then I calculated how many do we
likely have left so she's seven in about
what five years she's going to be 12 and
wanna go to the coffee shop with her
friends instead of me sad so the word
that's going to limit it and then she's
going to go off to college and probably
live you know across the country
and so I calculated
we probably have about 230 coffee dates
together left that is 35 of our coffee
dates left
that's less than half quite a bit less
than half and she's only seven
so what is that what's the impact on
that initially like yes tear in my eye
but the bigger effect is that I
prioritize this time I make this time so
when it was on Thursday mornings
meetings were scheduled around it they
didn't start before nine
now that it shifted to Saturday mornings
activities are scheduled around it but
not only is it about prioritizing that
time it is when I'm spending that time
knowing just how limited and precious
those moments are then I remove
destruction so like my cell phone goes
away that like constant to-do list
that's running through my mind is always
like okay what do I need to do next like
what's coming up in that planning gets
quieted because this is the time of my
life this is these are the important
moments
um and recognizing that they're limited
makes us pay more attention I got a
Memento Mori calendar that counts down
to 80. have you seen these and it's in
weeks of your life oh I haven't but so
you can imagine that you actually buy it
pre-filled in so you tell them your age
and they pre-fill in the first whatever
like 50 multiplied by your 52 multiplied
by your age in terms of squares and that
I guess it's kind of similar because
you're looking at what is it that I've
got left
thing that comes to mind when you're
talking about that is the relationship
between a child and the parent that you
spend 18 years or whatever living out of
each other's pockets and for the last
portion of that those teenagers just
hating each other and constantly having
arguments and storming up the stairs and
feeling like you're in a prison
and then you leave and in retrospect I
mean it must be in terms of hours spent
with your parents
almost all people in the western world
must be looking at the final 10 percent
like at the age of 18. yeah at the age
of 18 you've spent 90 of the time that
you're ever going to spend with your
parents again maybe even less I guess I
recently took my mum to Rome she hadn't
been away on holiday for ages and I
wanted to do something nice and me and
her went away to Rome and we spent four
days four in a tiny bit of days together
and I put her in a side car I did a I
made her do a Vespa tour around Rome in
a motorbike inside car and put it and it
looks like Wallace and Gromit is the
funniest thing and uh that that was me
one of the things I was very conscious
of there was wow I haven't spent this
much time around my mother in
15
7 16 years
16 years since I've spent four days and
around four days
like it's not that long and yeah I I
like the idea of starting with the end
in mind of using the precariousness of
what it is that we've got and also the
other thing I suppose is that
even without working out how many
accurately working out how many of these
things you've got left
life situations can change pretty
rapidly and the housemate that you live
with now might not live with you again
in six months time I I love watching uh
series on TV with one of my housemates
it's back in the UK but I live in Austin
now I didn't know that I was going to
live in Austin I was going to try it out
and see if I enjoyed it and now I'm here
and you know there will be I mean Sam
Harris talks about this as well there
will be a last time that you bounce your
baby daughter on your knee you know
there will be a she will get too big or
not want to do it anymore or some
situation will occur
this could be the last time this could
be the final time
that you get to be abroad with your
mother that you get to be on the couch
with your friends [ __ ] talking the
world's greatest athletes as they
perform as well as they can and yes I
think
adding a a sense of seriousness
like absolutely this this has important
consequences this isn't something that
should be taken lightly if it's if
you're deriving this much pleasure from
something you should take it seriously
because you take [ __ ] seriously that
means nothing you take [ __ ] seriously
all the time that is completely
arbitrary the argument with a stranger
on the internet that you're never going
to think about again you took that more
seriously than the activity today that
gave you the most joy and yes I like the
idea all of that creating perspective
scarcity understanding the scarcity
understanding the lack that you have uh
reflecting on what's how important it is
to you and using that as a projection to
remind yourself of the scarcity moving
forward I think all of that's great yeah
and what you're picking up on is so it's
that sort of difference between what's
important versus what seems urgent and
we tend to dedicate our time and our
thoughts to what is urgent irrespective
of its importance and yeah by thinking
about recognizing the preciousness The
Limited nature the finite nature of the
time we have with these people we love
doing these things that we love that
increases the urgency and makes it to
recognize how urgent it is and
interestingly in our research
we find actually
that people who think about their time
from a broader perspective so our
thinking in terms of their years and
their life overall instead of just
thinking hour by hour they actually are
happier and Report greater meaning in
their life and one of the drivers is
because they spend their hours on what's
important
irrespective of its urgency and so it
gives you you use the term perspective
absolutely it does that so taking that
perspective of your life and from taking
that broader life perspective it pulls
out what is important to you so in
happier hour I have a few exercises that
do encourage not just counting times
left but to take this broader life
perspective and some of them are quite
poignant but they're so important
because they're so clarifying so one of
them for instance is writing your eulogy
this is and some of my students I will
say are like what I thought this was a
happiness class and you're having me my
own eulogy
and so what this exercise is is
basically projecting forward assuming
you live a long life
in writing down how do you want to be
remembered so what are the words you
want people to use to describe you
um what life do you want to have lived
and I point out to one of my students
was like I am sorry Professor but I
can't do this assignment like thinking
about my death and creates too much
anxiety I'm gonna like forfeit my grid
I'm like okay let me reframe the
exercise or the assignment for you write
about the life that you want to live
because that's essentially what it is
it's not an exercise about death it's
about what life do you want to live and
writing that down and articulating
clarifies what's important what are your
values who do you want to be and with
that clarification what is your purpose
like what are your ultimate goals
with that
that even though it's thinking about
years and life overall that informs how
we spend our upcoming hours right it's
surely it's only
in contrast of how we want to spend our
time that we can look at the way we
spend our time
like it's like a subtraction okay it's
what what is it that I want to achieve
what is it that I'm doing that's getting
me toward achieving that and that's not
the lean in go-getter type a thing it's
I want to achieve a life which involves
lots of outdoor activities and whatever
right yeah but you can only contrast
those two if you have an end goal if you
have some sort of destination I had Ryan
holiday on last week and he was talking
about how uh discipline without a
destination is basically impossible
because what are you being disciplined
in service of like what is your
discipline working toward perhaps your
your life goal in some alternate
universe that was hell would be to spend
as much time on Tick Tock as possible
well discipline would involve you
spending as much time on Tick Tock as
possible right I want to be the most
watch the most number of hours of tick
tock of anybody on the planet that's my
life goal it is only in comparison with
the things that you want to do that you
can look at discipline and it kind of
feels like the way that you spend your
time is pretty much exactly the same
yeah and the thing
um
that I actually see among my MBA
students that I think that folks can all
relate to is
the importance so without your own clear
sense of purpose of your own goal and
what you're striving for then we pick up
on other people's goals like these
General Notions of success
and those General Notions of success
it's a terrible thing to be striving for
because a it's so amorphous it's so
multi-dimensional and a lot of it is
extrinsically driven and not
intrinsically so it's not what you
ultimately care about it's sort of like
this General sense of like what you
should do and what one does do
um and that is
very difficult because
um
what
it's it's not difficult it what it does
do is it leads to unhappiness because
it's like a the thing is like the goal
the post is always changing right it's
like this General like if success is
having a lot of money but then as you
make more money your reference point of
how you're doing shifts because you're
surrounded by people who also have more
money or fame you know it's like you're
surrounded by people who you're all of a
sudden in like a different room and
you're like how am I doing compared to
those around me well there's always
someone doing better right but the value
and for you identifying what matters to
you and your own purpose and your own
ultimate goals
is that
that is where what you're talking about
with this idea of like that's the
comparison that should motivate you it's
like if you're not aligned or like
living out what you care about then that
should you know kick you in the butt and
make you start working in line with that
but also it's it's great because when
you are achieving along that route it is
so much more rewarding
um
because it's it's what you care about
like and you said and like each step
along the way and actually going back to
even thinking about activities and how
we should be spending our time in your
time tracking you know there might be
activities that aren't fun so there's
those that are maybe wasted time like
The Tick Tock example is like you're
spending a lot of time on it it's not
necessary nor is it very fun but then
there's also some of these activities
that
yours
that are actually necessary
that was something I noticed about your
your example uh commuting to work uh
being at work and housework yeah for
most people those are relatively
non-negotiable the things that they
can't Outsource they can't get someone
else to go to work for them they can't
get someone to drive them to work they
can't get someone else to do the
housework so yeah there has to be a
solution in order to make these things
that's beautiful
so there are so there are some
strategies for the commuting for
instance is something that you have to
do
um and bundling is actually one of the
strategies that coming out of research
by Katie Milkman and her colleagues it's
such a simple idea but it's very
effective and what it is is like you
take this activity that you don't want
to do but is necessary like
driving to work or commuting or whatever
it means or like folding the laundry you
know we have household chores
and bundling it with an activity that
you do enjoy that is more worthwhile so
whether it's picking up the phone we
talked about the role of social
connection picking up the phone and
calling your friend while you're folding
the laundry or commuting or listening to
a wonderful enriching enlightening
podcast right here subscribed below
thank you Cassie show the channel that's
what you're here for thank you exactly
but I mean like joking aside absolutely
so all of a sudden instead of like
oftentimes during a commute when
someone's driving flipping through the
radio mindlessly or if they're on the
tube or Subway
um flicking through their Tick Tock and
instead of If instead of that sort of
filling of time if you spent that time
intentionally listening to a podcast
where you learn something that you're
inspired by then all of a sudden that
time that you're just sort of trying to
get through of the commute all of a
sudden feels more worthwhile and
stretched let me give you my most recent
bundling solution so great I have quite
a lot of emails that I need to deal with
and I can't really Outsource them or
maybe I just struggle at delegating
control my personal assistant might
might agree with that
um I bought an exercise desk which is a
recumbent stationary bike that has a
flat it's built it's purpose built right
and you put the laptop on top of it
there's something called Zone 2 cardio
which is cardio between around about 110
to 130 BPM heart rate for most people
and it's actually kind of hard to
achieve because it's not as quick as a
run a run would take you way over it
probably into the 140s but it's quicker
than a walk so it's kind of difficult to
work out how you're going to mediate
this particular pace and it's also you
have to do it for quite a while you need
to accumulate around about 180 minutes
per week if you want to get a very good
impact but it's the train slow to run
fast blah blah blah tons of health
benefits longevity and heart rate
variability and resting heart rate and
blah blah blah uh but it's really hard
to do emails also suck so now when I do
my emails I just sit on the bike I set
it away for an hour I have
um I've got Parkinson's law going on so
I've restricted down my time to have a
goal and I'm like right I'm good yeah
got to get my thing done so I got 60
minutes and I know and I can see it
counting down or whatever I'm gonna get
the cardio in that I would have kind of
it's it's satisfying it does make me
feel good but it's not
it it would be really awful to do on its
own and yet I take so much pleasure from
doing it while I do my my emails it's
insane and then I get my emails finished
I actually I genuinely look forward to
doing emails because I'm like I'm gonna
go get a bit of cardio and get a nice
sweater on I'm gonna feel really good
once I've finished up so yeah I'm aware
that that that's like the most hyper
nerdy solution uh to this but also
listening to podcasts on your commute is
it is another one I I am very
appreciative of this um suggestion
though because email is my source of
least happiness
um and so if I'm if there's a way to
bend it 360 books will get you an extra
exit work exodesk 2000i and it will
change your life oh my gosh and then you
can hang clothes on it when you're not
using it as well it's fantastic
talk about a persuasive advertisement
yeah I'm not even sponsored not even
sponsored by them right so you've you've
brought up a couple of times here the
import importance of social connection
you mentioned intimacy which is
presumably like relationship partner
stuff as well how
can people develop their friendships and
deepen their friendships because one of
the things that I hear a lot is a
difficulty in people finding friends
especially guys I think when they get
into adulthood you know you don't have
the same structures that maybe through
school through uni sports teams stuff
like that I think guys especially when
they get married there's a ton of
evidence that suggests they just adopt
the friends of their partner and that's
now their friend group but even that
starts to dwindle over time as well
um so what about deepening friendships
what are some of the strategies people
can use to do that yeah and so there's a
exercise in
um my that I share in the book and that
I have my students do which is called
the relationship closeness induction
task but basically what it is it is a
series of questions and this this takes
15 minutes and I will loop back to how
this can be implemented to sort of Forge
friendships
um it's a it's a 15-minute task so
basically it starts with
um
I think it's like three minutes that it
and in these questions you like you're
paired up I pair my students up and they
have two minutes to ask a question they
ask a question the person answers it and
then the other person and asks the same
question and they answer it so it's
reciprocal
um and then the first few minutes is
like these
what you talk about when you meet
someone like what's your name what made
you decide to come in this case it's
like to UCLA to get your MBA
um you know where are you from these
things that you know are those initial
get to know you conversations but then
I'm like okay guys now move on to the
second set of questions and the second
set of questions are a little bit more
self-disclosive so they are like what do
you like to spend your time on like your
hobbies and your experiences
um so you get to hear about the other
person's experiences and how they spend
their time and then the last set of
questions uh they have eight minutes
um to go through and these are
deeper these are like what are you most
proud about in your life what is your
happiest childhood memory what is your
greatest fear
and these questions aren't just about
how you spend your time it's really your
emotional experience in your life and
this is a method that's been shown to
make people feel significantly closer
and like they are more like friends at
the end of it even though it's 15
minutes but what it's doing it's based
off of
reciprocal escalating self-disclosure so
what that means is that it is
sharing
and asking and listening so it has to be
not just you like dumping like oh my god
this is my biggest fear and this is what
I'm really struggling with but also
asking the other person and listening
what is what are you struggling with
and through that what friendship is it's
about this sense of being known
and being cared about and knowing and
caring so there is that reciprocal
um feature of it and so
in
you know like you were talking about
often in shared experiences when we're
in experiences together that's an
opportunity to develop that sort of
shared experience like when you go to
college or university
um that shared experience starting a new
job together
um often you know with all of us or so
many of us working remotely actually the
opportunity to develop actual friendship
at work has really waned and that's what
I am attributing the increased
disengagement from work that we've uh
observed in the workforce
um to the fact that folks don't have
friends and not an opportunity so to say
that yes
it is about finding activities that you
you know like people who like doing the
same thing but it just showing up and
doing the activity together isn't going
to be where the real friendship comes
from it's from having that conversation
that conversation that gets authentic
and you are being vulnerable and you are
supporting the other person and their
vulnerability so
to the point
be ready to ask the good questions when
you're hanging out with someone and also
be real willing to share
note that not
sometimes you need that escalating sort
of component of the conversation so that
you don't like freak people out
um but it's uh it's always surprising by
how
happy people are to really get genuine
um and so it's just up to you to be
willing to get there too didn't your
husband ask you some insightly intense
questions the first time that you met
yeah so I shared that
um in the book
um my husband and I he is I mean he's
such a wonderful person and he he's like
my favorite conversation partner still
to this day and we were set up on a
blind date
of her coffee and he like his first
question was like a very last one in
those relationship closeness induction
task he was like what to you is the
secret or not the secret like what are
you striving for for like a happy good
life and I'm like oh wait what about
like what are my hobbies and what made
me decide to come to Stanford
um he skipped all of that and it was so
refreshing and so coming out of even
that first coffee date I was like wow
I feel like I know someone and am a
little bit known
um by this stranger and so I think that
that that is an example that is has
proven well for me in terms of
establishing a really beautiful
relationship
I think a lot of people have problems at
the moment with the shallow sort of
nature of conversations that they have I
think it's another reason why podcasts
have got so much popularity because you
get to kind of almost hear
sometimes conversations that you wish
that you could have a little bit more I
mean I I know for me there's the reason
that I enjoyed starting this show four
and a half years ago 500 something
episodes ago is because I was struggling
to have the frequency and depth of
conversation that I wanted and if I was
able to do it on the podcast you have an
excuse to kind of bypass all of this so
tell me about you and what did you have
for breakfast and what are you up to
tomorrow like people don't expect that
they expect you to kind of pretty
quickly get into the meat of the
performance with this and um yeah I I
think that
you're right that the escalation you're
going to turn some people off but if
you're the sort of person for whom you
want to kind of speed through minutes
one through ten and get into the final
five I I think that that makes a lot of
sense and I think that more people than
realize it would resonate with like a
really interesting deep conversation
when I think about what most of my 20s
is a very normal bloke in the UK just
being a a club promoter around a range
of young people that were relatively
outgoing and whatever whatever
so few people had conversations like the
ones that they wanted to I think they
had conversations that were very surface
level that were about TV or current
events but not important current events
just like and I think that uh that might
just be a byproduct of being young right
it might just be a byproduct of being in
your 20s I don't know I don't think so I
think that
um those are the types of conversations
that generally are had in Social
settings like social settings with big
groups so actually touching back to the
time tracking exercise that I suggest
folks do the reason that I say it's so
important to not just sort of write
socializing as your activity but
actually
who are you with and also going back and
looking at okay well what were those
activities that I felt like most
connecting and that might be like for
some for me it absolutely requires a
genuine conversation
and but that genuine conversation can
happen in a lot of different contexts it
can happen with a colleague at work it
can happen with
um like someone at a cocktail party as I
am only satisfied when I leave one of
these sort of cocktail parties if I come
out I'm like oh my God I got that person
was so cool and so interesting
but so it's like finding those ways
those activities and but also the pieces
of that activity that uh um that sort of
make you feel most connected so that
it's the onus is on you not only to put
yourself
spend time on those activities that make
you feel that way but really
make that time what you want it to be
um by showing up having driving the
conversation and I agree with you people
are more willing than they might
initially think
um it's just because it doesn't often
happen doesn't mean that it won't be fun
and that you know and just give it give
it a shot
um
talk to me about the time poverty and
time affluence relationship yeah
it drove me
to write the book
um and what it is is this acute feeling
of having too much to do and not enough
time to do it and when we feel like we
don't have enough time it's this really
limiting
um experience and it is experienced as
stress and it makes us unhappy and it
also makes us less healthy so research
shows that when people feel
um like they're they don't have enough
time they're less likely to exercise
they're less likely there's a delay
going to the doctor it also makes us
less nice
um we are less likely to slow down and
help others out
um and it makes us less confident in
being able to achieve all we set out to
do because of the sense of limitation
and it makes us less happy and I uh I I
share as a to open the book this time
earlier in my career when I was living
in Philly
and I was an assistant professor at
Wharton and had given it was just one of
these crazy days where I traveled up to
New York to give a talk and this my
presentation was sandwiched in between
back-to-back meetings and then I had
this colleague dinner and then I was
rushing to get the very last train that
would get me home to my four-month-old
at the time and my husband asleep in
Philly
and I did make the train but I remember
like looking out the window as
like the night was passing by and the
houses were like in this blur and I was
like I don't know if I can keep up
there's just I'm exhausted and
overwhelmed Between the pressures of
work being a good partner being a good
parent
being a good friend like the
never-ending pile of chores there simply
weren't enough hours in the day to get
it all done let alone to do any of it
well let alone to enjoy any of it along
the way
and that feeling made me at that moment
think okay the solution is to quit
I should quit my job that I'd worked so
hard to get
um because surely if I move to a sunny
you know slow pace Island somewhere I'd
be happy if I had a whole lot more time
I was like then I will be happier
but before I quit I was like this is
actually an empirical question like are
people who have a whole lot more time
happier
and this is a question that we've gone
on to test and looking at with some of
my beloved collaborators Hal hirschfield
and Marissa Sharif we looked at what's
the relationship between the amount of
discretionary time people have and their
life satisfaction and analyzing across
studies and one of the studies we
analyzed data from tens of thousands of
working as well as non-working Americans
calculating how much discretionary time
they had in their days time spent on
discretionary activities and what we
found was really interesting is this
upside down u-shape so sort of reaching
down to unhappiness on both sides on the
one hand on the left side with too
little time people are less happy that
is the time poor that is me on the train
um but what was interesting was on the
other side that you also saw this
downward slope to unhappiness and so it
suggested that there's actually such
thing as having too much discretionary
time and then digging into that what it
turns out is like people are driven to
be productive that is we are averse to
being idle when we spend days upon days
with all of our hours and nothing to
show for that how we spent those hours
it undermines our sense of purpose and
with that we feel dissatisfied
and so this is really important to
recognize that and actually in in the
middle of that upside down you it's
pretty flat so it's not about how much
time you have it's really with the
conclusion from this and I is what drove
the book it's not actually about how
much time you have available to spend
how you want it is how you spend the
time that you have available so it's not
about being time Rich it's about making
the time that you spend rich
it's about as we've said
identifying what are those activities
that are really worthwhile
and when you're spending your time on
those activities being fully engaged not
being distracted so that you get the
happiness that is available in that
activity
and
um
so but when I'm saying time Rich it's
about
looking back on your day and feeling
fulfilled not about not being busy
because you can actually be quite busy
but if you've spent time on things that
felt worthwhile then you don't feel
depleted you feel fulfilled and
satisfied and that's the goal and so
that's actually what motivated or sort
of directed my research agenda since of
like okay how should we be investing the
hours of our days so that again at the
end of the day instead of feeling
depleted and stressed and overwhelmed
and unhappy you look back and you feel
satisfied and fulfilled and like excited
for the next day to do to do more right
and so
the
with so many people feeling time poor so
we conducted a national poll
um in the U.S finding that nearly half
of Americans feel like they don't have
enough time
um to do what they set out and want to
do
um and that's bad because of all those
reasons that I said
um but actually we have more time
available to us
than we think and when we spend that
time in ways that feel really worthwhile
that gives us energy that lessens the
sense of constraint and limitation and
actually that increased sense of
efficacy of being able to accomplish
what you set out to do increases your
sense of how much time you feel like you
have available and when I'm talking
about time available this is hours
within your days not what we were
talking about at the very beginning of
like the limited nature of your life
um you talk about this discretionary
time am I right in thinking that the
bottom end where things stop being bad
was about one hour and the top end when
things start to get bad again is five
hours is that the bracket
um it's two hours and five hours so with
less than approximately two hours of
discretionary time at least in the data
set the American time use survey data
then we saw that sort of drop off in
happiness and more than approximately
five hours is where we saw that drop off
in happiness now interestingly for Sam
and I will admit for me at the time I
was like two hours sounds like
a luxury there's no way two hours is
like in the day to you know spend on
discretionary activities but then when I
actually calculated
the hours of my days that I spend doing
what I love like
cuddling with my little you know my
little baby having dinner with my
husband that wonderful conversationalist
that I've already referenced
um having a giving a call to my best
friend on my walk home you know we
talked about yes commuting is bad
but when I'm talking to one of my
favorite people that those those minutes
added up to about like an hour and a
half
of time that I wouldn't have wanted to
spend in any other way
and that's helpful because it suggests
that in fact two hours isn't totally Out
Of Reach
um but it does require being intentional
about the time it does require
um particularly if you do work full-time
and have other demands it does require
um sifting out that wasted time that
sand that the sort of tick tock time
or what you can identify for yourself
what thought wasted time is for you it
does require minimizing the waste
so that you do and prioritize and make
the time for the stuff that really
matters to you I think a lot of people
when first faced with this will probably
have a little bit of
of difficulty because they'll confuse a
comfortable or convenient activity for
an enjoyable one so they'll finish up at
the end of the work day and get home and
well the way that I relax is by watching
Netflix for a couple of hours on an
evening with a glass of wine you go I I
understand but what else is there
something else that you could be doing
which would be more enjoyable and
because it's less comfortable or
convenient it's presumed as being like
more work oh well I've just finished
work I don't have to go and do more work
it's like okay look objectively would
you prefer to spend your evening going
out and seeing your friends or going and
playing a new sport or whatever it is
that you whatever the thing is that you
want to do as opposed to this thing
which is just a path of least resistance
what would you tomorrow have wanted you
today to have done like would you are
you going to look back tomorrow on the
way that you spent your evening watching
yet another [ __ ] Netflix series with yet
another very average glass of wine or
would you get much more enjoyment both
in the moment and in retrospect had you
have gone to go and see your friends
that was the biggest thing it was Laura
vanderkam four and a bit years ago
who taught me about the experiencing
anticipating and remembering self and
just having that model in my mind has
changed like I go and do so much stupid
stupid uh novel stuff because I think
well if I do this even if it's
completely terrible i've got an awesome
memory that's going to stay in my mind
and that's going to expand the units
that I'm gonna have that'll make my life
feel like it goes longer and all the
rest of this stuff
so yeah I think getting past the
mistaking a comfortable or convenient
activity for an enjoyable one I think
that's a really important thing
especially for people that are super
super busy spent a long day at work got
the kids up earlier in the morning so on
and so forth
um so going on from that how do you
think people should think about the
relationship between time and money
because that's for most people is a
um hugely correlated uh situation yeah
and even before we got to the time and
money
um sort of interaction I I think that
the time tracking exercise is the reason
it's so powerful is to combat exactly
what you're talking about this General
notion that people have of like oh I
enjoy watching TV because that's sort of
what I do but if you actually have the
data in front of you and it's like well
not really like it is the path of
release resistance I mean that happens
to be what you are mindlessly doing it
sort of fills default into it yeah but
it doesn't mean that it's actually what
you enjoy doing and if you're picking up
on like you know like and this and what
comes out it's like people are like oh I
don't have time to meet up with my
friend my sister for dinner
but in fact
you do like instead of going back home
and getting on the couch in that sort of
uh default is it's it's not work like
text your sister and be like let's meet
up and then when you do and you're out
you're like that gets a 10 instead of
the you know four of like that third
hour of Netflix right and so with that
objective numerical data that is your
very own right there in front of you
then that is what helps motivate and
Kickstart into spending time in these
ways that are really impactful and to
your point and Laura's point
and actually like going back to my
example with my coffee date with my
daughter
the effect on happiness
carries over Beyond just the time that
you're spending right so there's that
anticipation of it so like I look
forward to my coffee date with my
daughter she looks forward to it and
then when we're in it we're spending it
so it's like 30 minutes of delectable
like sweetness
but then we remember it and we talk
about it and if you ask me how happy I
am I am like genuinely so happy because
again what is happiness is thinking
about
our time and our lives and when you ask
me how happy I am I'm like pulling it's
like well I have this amazing
relationship with my daughter
from
really this like like cultivate and
stemming from that 30 minutes it's just
30 minutes unfortunately because I work
I don't know if it's unfortunate I don't
anyway I don't pick up my kids from
school at three o'clock every day like
you know many parents do
because I can't I work
but that doesn't mean just because I'm
not spending that time these coffee
dates are really these quality time that
color not only how I experience the week
but my relationships and from that is
where the happiness
um comes from
um to your question of time and money
um
my dissertation work was actually
looking at what's the effect of focusing
on time versus money
um and our critical resource and
um what my studies over the court in
lots of different ways have shown that
those who focus on time
um as their critical resource or happier
and really it is because they invest
their time more intentionally it's not
default evenings it is not allowing your
time to be soaked up by on Tick Tock it
is about being intentional and spending
time in ways that matter to you
thinking about money
um actually has uh its own effect and it
sort of drives towards these extrinsic
goals whereas when you think about time
it's driving you to invest your time in
these activities that are aligned with
your intrinsicles your purpose now
it's not like money is bad because money
can actually be spent
to improve our time and the research
that looks at what are the happiest ways
of spending money all I mean my
interpretation of them is that it's all
about making your time better so it is
Outsourcing actually so putting some
money against our if there are
activities or chores in your life that
absolutely feel like a chore
um and that are pulling you out of time
that you can spend in these ways that
are aligned with your goals of whether
it is investing or cultivating your
relationships investing in activities
that really allow you to fulfill your
purpose
then
um then that is time well spent and to
wash your car pay someone to do the
gardening pay someone to perhaps come
and do some laundry or something yeah
but it doesn't even have to be so clear
as like paying someone so that you don't
have to do it there are Services now
like the whole like deliver like grocery
shopping so yes you are paying someone
to do their groceries or
um delivery servant like meal services
where it is like so that it saves you
from doing the grocery shopping and the
time cooking a lot of it is prepped and
so that that is Saving Time and yes you
are paying money it is more expensive to
have this meal delivery service than if
you were to go and pick out the you know
the produce and everything and put it
together yourself but what you've done
is you've saved time and then you can
spend that time in those ways and so
this is like such a clear trade-off for
uh me as a working mom
instead of leaving work early to go
grocery shopping or coming home late
which is those precious hours with my
kids before they go to bed so that I'm
grocery shopping and then like cooking
which I hate to do anyway
um like the meal service it costs a
little bit more money but then I get the
extra time at work that I need and then
my evening is not cooking dinner and
cleaning up dishes it is sitting with my
family and you know hanging out with my
kids helping them with their homework
hearing about their days having that
wonderful conversation with my husband
um so also research looks at uh
pro-social spending uh that spending
money on other people actually makes us
happier than spending money on ourselves
and off and also my work shows that
giving experiential gifts versus
material gifts
um increases a sense of connection the
recipient feels closer to you and so
pairing that together as well as
research showing that experiential
purchases like going out to dinner going
to a concert going on vacation versus
material purchases like buying a handbag
or I don't know other material purchases
actually which tend to be material
purchases Electronics
um
that people have greater happiness from
their experiential purchases because
they have the experience of spending
that time so it is time that you're
spending but you also have the memory
oftentimes those experiences are shared
if you're giving an experiential gift
like taking someone out to dinner
getting them tickets for a concert that
is a shared experience
um versus buying yourself a handbag so
again the sort of spending money in ways
that buy you better time more fulfilling
time
and connect you with other people
and Foster those you know relationships
um
that is money well spent so it's not and
it's also I think it's super important
to not ignore the fact that people who
don't have enough money to satisfy their
basic needs yes more money in the
research shows leads to Greater
happiness but actually what it's not is
not greater happiness is reducing the
unhappiness the stress and the pressures
of not being able to satisfy your needs
that's very interesting I mean there's
been so much so much of the
um over seventy thousand dollars per
year happiness starts to tail off then I
had Seth Stevens davidowitz on at the
start of the uh and he seemed to suggest
that
um for every increment of increase in
I want to say life satisfaction was the
measurement rather than happiness you
needed to double the amount of money so
in order for you to go from 70 to 140
you'd need to go from 140 to 280 and 280
to 560. is there any legs to that when
it comes to earning the relationship
between the money that you earn and your
happiness or satisfaction in life
um well it is like and actually it's
going on that sort of diminishing
returns these things have less impact
over time I talked about the role of
hedonic adaptation
um and so that's that's a piece of it it
comes from adapting to your
circumstances and then you need all the
more to have any effect on your
experience
um
and so
yes but the and that's why it's so
helpful to continue to come back to time
and what matters to you and your purpose
because then it is absolutely continues
to be rewarding when you are achieving
along those Dimensions as opposed to
these external ones I suppose as well it
stops you from overshooting now I'm
around some pretty competent people in
Austin and a lot of them are going to be
worth a hell of a lot of money within
the next decade or so right I mean we're
in the city that Elon Musk lives in so
the opportunities the ceiling is
Limitless and I think
thankfully most of them have done enough
self work to be able to check themselves
and go hang on just just how much do I
need to destroy myself in pursuit of an
amount of wealth that's 10 times as much
as the most amount of money that I would
need per year in order to be happy and
we were I was talking to a friend over
dinner about this last night I was like
look
if I 10xed my income I genuinely don't
know what I'd do like
I buy a slightly nicer coffee on a
morning on the days that I do have like
you know yeah I'm sure that the it would
be great to fly private and I'm sure it
would be great to do the whatever and
the other things but I I think that when
it comes to a a realistic expectation of
what's going to happen in life
optimizing for time optimizing for the
experiences that in retrospect you know
you're going to be glad that you've done
just seems to be a much safer way to go
about things and then if the byproduct
comes of you being worth 100 million in
10 years time then fantastic but great
you know that you're optimizing for the
things which actually matter
and or everything else is just extra
absolutely and that is uh you said it so
directly it's it's not only a safer
route to happiness it's the direct route
like it is if you are investing your
time
on the things that matter to you
then
you will be happier you will be more
satisfied and it's not more is better it
is just being intentional and spending
the time in ways that matter to you and
as you said if
if money comes along with it fantastic
like that's gravy
um and you do and again not uh ignoring
the fact that you do need to be able to
have enough money to satisfy your basic
needs it's so helpful to continue to
sort of touch back to Maslow's hierarchy
of needs
um because at the very base of it is you
need you have your physiological needs
you need food
shelter safety Health those are your
physiological needs the very next Once
those are satisfied and you need money
to put food on the table to live in a
safe place
um
uh but once those basic physiological
needs are met then the next most
fundamental need that we have is sense
of connection and belonging and that's
where these relationships come into play
and then it's like once you like are
shored up and like make sure that you
have strong relationships then you sort
of move into this confidence and
self-actualization where it's these sort
of more individual Pursuits but
you do need enough money to and and like
I
I have been doing the work long enough
of like comparing time and money and I I
am sensitive to like it's not that much
having any money doesn't matter but
having a whole lot more money also
doesn't matter
Cassie Holmes ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you do where should they go
um my website cassiamhomes.com
um and then my book I mean it pulls it
all together
um these learnings based off of my
career research and teaching the course
for years and seeing the effects and so
I'm so excited
um to bring these learnings to people
more generally and make people happier
with their time thank you Cassie I
appreciate you thanks so much for having
me what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]